it's not just here in georgia
last year alone 19 states
not proposed but enacted 34 laws
attacking voting rights
there were nearly 400 additional bills
republican members of state legislatures
tried to pass
and now
republican legislators in several states
have already announced plans to escalate
the onslaught this year
it's about making it harder to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
and whether your vote counts at all
the goal the former president's allies
is to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them simple as that
the facts won't matter
your vote won't matter
they'll just decide what they want
and then do it
i've been having these quiet
conversations with members of congress
for the last two months i'm tired of
being quiet
not a single republican
has displayed the courage to stand up
to a defeated president
to protect america's right to vote not
one
not one
today
i'm making it clear
to protect our democracy
i support changing the senate rules
whichever way they need to be changed to
prevent
a minority of senators from blocking
action on voting rights
when it comes to protecting majority
rule
in america the majority should rule in
the united states senate
the next few days
when these bills come to a vote
will mark a turning point in this
nation's history
will we choose
democracy over autocracy
light
over shadows
justice over injustice
i know where i stand
i will not yield i will not flinch i
will defend the right to vote our
democracy against all enemies foreign
and yes domestic
and the question is
where will the institution of the united
states senate stand